well police in new jersey clearly don't
want to but they're being forced to
harass
people working out in the gym handcuff
them threaten them with jail
far less attention has been paid to the
people who've actually
died from the coronavirus because
they're vulnerable government has done
so little to protect them
even as it prevents you from playing
doubles tennis or
swimming in pennsylvania and new york
possibly in other states nursing homes
were told they were required
to admit patients infected with the
coronavirus
outbreaks inevitably resulted
thousands died leaders didn't care in
pennsylvania
in perhaps the most shocking and
offensive example
of all illustrating just how little
government cares about you
the health commissioner of the
commonwealth rachel levine moved her own
mother out of a nursing home before she
could fall
victim to the resulting death trap doug
mastriano is a pennsylvania state
senator he watched this with his jaw
open he joins us tonight thanks so much
mr masternode for coming on
as many times as we tell this story it's
hard to believe that it's true that your
state health director moved her own
mother out of a nursing home and then
forced nursing homes to admit
infected patients but that's true is it
not
it is and you can't make this stuff up
so last monday i called for
levine's resignation yeah and then the
next day we find out that the secretary
did these shenanigans with uh
the secretary's own mom evacuating mom
to a safe secure location at a lodge a
deluxe suite
and so what about the rest of the
parents grandparents aunts and uncles
and this sort of thing
you just never imagine it's going to
happen in america especially
pennsylvania the birthplace of
independence and freedom
but it did and actually needs to be
taken this is like a bad movie every day
we wake up and it's still being played
on a b-roll and i feel like the keystone
cops are running the keystone state god
help us
that's for sure and god help the people
trapped in nursing homes they can't have
their loved ones visit them they're
alone many are dying
i don't hear our leaders talk about them
at all we saw andrew cuomo saying every
life is precious
and then he forced infected patients
into nursing homes
thousands died and he's telling us well
people die it's like does anyone care
it doesn't seem like that and the sad
thing is that they actually
rightly predicted this a lot of things
that got wrong and the modeling would
have you know how catastrophic it was
going to be
but we heard over and over again from
governor wolf and secretary levine
that the most vulnerable would be the
elderly and those with health conditions
and indeed that was exactly it but then
why on 18 march with our secretary of
health
issue this memorandum directing the
homes to take covet-positive patients
back to free up hospital beds i mean
it's utter madness and two-thirds of the
debts
in pennsylvania are coming out of this
and there needs to be accountability
tell me that democrats in the state
legislature aren't defending
your health director levine
they are and you know i retired from the
army two years ago and maybe i'm
off my rocker but i thought at some
point we'd come together and agree when
there's a sheer incompetence
and the secretary has been delivering
nothing but medical malpractice here and
this is something we definitely can come
together on but instead they're circling
the wagons here and defending this
administration and it's utter madness
has levine apologized for moving your
own mother out
of a nursing home and then dooming the
the people
stuck there to death
so obviously levine knew that the the
secretary's gonna be asked this question
on
last tuesday had a prepared statement it
was absolutely absurd ridiculous
you can't make this stuff up no apology
you know it would have been one thing
tucker if the secretary came out you two
months ago and said look i'm not sure
that we could safeguard your family
members your loved ones so maybe if you
can take them out of the homes for a
couple months but instead special
treatment
exactly it would be like liquidating
your stock portfolio and telling the
country everything was going to be fine
we saw that too
it tells you they don't care at all
about you uh thanks so much
for joining us tonight i really
appreciate it thank you tucker
well speaking of the dangers in nursing
homes amy glenn who's the widow of
astronaut and former senator from ohio
john glenn died today of the chronovirus
at a nursing home in st
paul minnesota she was a hundred years
old
annie and john glenn were married an
astonishing 73 years
quite a life